hello everyone welcome to this
manning live stream the second live
stream i'm
doing actually and today we're going to
talk about
the concept of cognitive loads and code
smells
my name is felina hermans and i'm the
author of the programmer's brain a book
that is now
out as a manning early access program so
you can look at
the book already the first nine chapters
are currently available online to read
and the
book is also out for pre-order i think
you're gonna enjoy this live stream
most if you either watched my previous
live stream that's available also on
manning's youtube channel
or you've already read a few chapters of
my book because
in this video we're gonna really dive
deeper into some of the concepts that
have been covered before
so if you've never seen or read anything
then maybe the best thing you can do is
first to check out other content because
this might otherwise be a little bit
um too detailed and too deep so let's
dive
into some of the things the book and the
previous video talked about
so we talked about cognitive load which
is the idea
of the busyness of your brain like
how hard is your brain working on a
problem
and cognitive load like how hard your
brain is working can be divided into
three different types three different
subtypes of cognitive loads
that are very very relevant once we
start talking about code smells
and the first type of cognitive load is
called
intrinsic load an intrinsic cognitive
load
is cognitive load that is just related
to the problem for example
here you see in this calculation if you
have to calculate the length
of this side of the triangle then you
you just
need to be able to add a square and b
squared together
and then you get c square you have to
take the root of this
so any problem has as we would call this
in programming like in
an intrinsic inherit complexity and
inherent complexity
creates intrinsic load there's nothing
really we can do about that
however the way is certain problem is
phrased
can give extra cognitive load and this
extra cognitive load we call this
extraneous cognitive load
so if you phrase your problem in a
certain way like rather than
putting the six and the eight on the
triangle
you put an a and the b on the triangle
and then you put the
values of the a and b somewhere else
this is the same problem right i haven't
changed anything about the problem
but the phrasing has made it slightly
more difficult
to now do the calculation because
mentally you have to
move the six and move the eight this
type of
load is called extraneous load
additional accidental complexity is what
you might say in programming
where you're adding complexity that
isn't necessarily
needed then there's a third type of
cognitive load as well
the third type of cognitive load is
called germain
loads and your main load is the the
effort that your brain needs to actually
store
stuff into your long term memory
so your brain shouldn't be all too full
because if your brain is entirely filled
with intrinsic and extraneous cognitive
loads then you'll be able to do
something you will be able to process
the programs
but you will not be able to remember the
program so these three types
of cognitive loads play a large role if
we start to examine code smells
so that was just a brief recap of
cognitive load and as i said
if this was a little bit quick because
you haven't heard about those concepts
before
then my book or my previous live stream
stream are great sources
to go in more depth into these contents
so now let's look at code smells
probably you're somewhat familiar with
the concept of code smells because it's
it's a very well known and sort of an
old idea already
in programming land the idea of code
smells was
first coined in martin fowler's book
refactoring
improving the design of existing codes
and this book
both coins the idea of code smells and
also the idea of refractorings which
are ways to relieve code smell so code
smells and refactoring
very much go hand in hand and they were
introduced together in fowler's book
so just to give you a sense of what is
code smells if you've never heard of
them
code smells are part of a program that
are not ideally structured so it isn't
necessarily an
error or a bug but it's just that your
code is
is not great right this is why it's
called code smells it's like
something's off here for example a long
method
you have a long method and it might very
well be that this method
is perfect that there's no error but you
know that if you have a method that's
like a hundred lines long
it's just harder to process than if you
have a method that's maybe five lines
long
or shorter even maybe a one-line method
can be
really quick to grasp what is there
long parameter lists can also be seen as
a code smell where
rather than a function with parameters x
and y
there's this super long we have some
examples later on in the slide
a function with a super long list of
like 11 or 12 parameters
and then you have to remember all the
parameters and again
it could be the case that this function
is working
perfectly there's nothing necessarily
wrong with it but
having many parameters is also somewhat
of a smell
and of course as i said smells and
refactorings go hand in hand so if you
have
a function that has a very very long
parameter list
maybe they're actually two functions
right maybe this function could be split
and then half the parameters are used in
one part on the other half
is used in another part so smells very
often
leads to a potential improvement
there are many other smells actually i
think the list of followers like 23
different code smells
i'm not gonna go over them i just i want
to give you a little bit more of a sense
of what we're going to talk about today
so other examples exist at the class
level so for example a class can have
many methods and fields
so many that it's not really clear what
the thing is doing anymore and this
happens sometimes if you have something
like a utilities class
rather than thinking oh this method that
i want to create
what object does this go with best like
i've certainly made the mistake of like
oh let's just put this in the utilities
class and this and this and then at one
point this is like this
this very very big blob of functionality
where some parts might actually rather
live
in a different class where they belong
better
the opposite of a large class is a lazy
class
so you can also have a class that's just
a little bit of data maybe
one or two functions that also didn't
really
doesn't really help readability because
then of course your code base gets
divided also over different
files because classes often live in the
wrong files so if you have
a little bit of functionality in a class
that's also a sign
that maybe something could be
restructured a bit
other smells that are commonly occurring
in code are
the duplicated code smell this is also
called
code cloning where you have
slightly different versions of the same
code or
sometimes it can also be exactly the
same code in different
places in the code base and this is an
issue because if you want to make a
change to one of the clones
then maybe you also want to make the
same change to other clones and you
might forget like where the
cool clone code is located so lots of
duplication
in a code base is also a sign that
something might be off
the final code smell i want to talk
about today in this video
is message chaining a message chaining
is a
code smell in which one function calls
another function and that function
then calls another
function and that calls another function
and very often it isn't just calling
functions
but it's also passing a blob of data so
i'm calling a function with a parameter
and then the next function is also
taking in this parameter
maybe adding more and then like like
like a ball like
sending the ball to the next person and
then the data hops through the entire
code base
and this might make debugging really
hard like
i've i've stepped to programs with a
debugger where you go into a function
like okay
this is where the error occurs let's see
what happens and then it goes
into another function into another
function and it takes a very very long
time
until you really have pinpointed where
an error for example is located or where
a certain operation is being called
so what you see here firstly is that the
code smells in fowler's
library in folders catalogue have very
very different scopes
and this is actually a new analysis that
we do in my book
that fowler didn't really do so finally
just had this
list of code smells and it's been a
great resource and many people have
really benefit from it greatly
including myself like i've done much
work
building on the idea of code smells
but the code smells in the catalogue are
very very different
in scope and we zoom into this a lot in
chapter 9 of the book
some code smells for example in this
small set of the
catalogue like long method and long
parameter list
are method level smells so they only
occur within the method i can look at a
method and i can decide
whether that's a long method or a short
matter like if i've said
what i think is long or short but this
is very much the method scope
there's also smells in fowler's
repository
that are at the class level so a large
class is a class level smell
and then there's code smells for example
like duplicated code and message
chain that exists at the code base level
like i cannot look at one method and
decide
is this duplicated code because the the
other
clone like the duplication of this
method by living a different class in
the same
code base and the reason why this is
important well firstly it can be
important for detection reasons right
like you want to understand
is this code-based smelly you have to
understand what is the scope
i need to examine but from the
perspective of what we talk about in
this video and in the book as well from
a
cognitive perspective these different
scopes of code smells also really do
different things to your brain and
that's what we're gonna zoom into
a little bit more in this talk so first
thing let's examine
in general like later in the video we'll
talk about specific examples of code
smells and why they are
troublesome from a cognitive perspective
but let's first look at
code smells in general like why are code
smells
problematic in general and to answer
that question we have to
go back to those three different types
of cognitive loads what code smells
do is they increase extraneous load
right so the the lowest level the
intrinsic load still stays the same
if you have a function that calculates
uh i don't know it calculates the square
or something it doesn't really matter if
you do this in one line or if you do
this in a thousand lines
for the inherent cognitive load for the
complexity of the problem itself it
doesn't really matter how you write it
but the way you phrase it is very much
gonna increase
potentially the extraneous cognitive
load the
extra effort that your brain has to
put in to understand the code so
extraneous load
is the part of cognitive loads where
code smells
create issues so diving a little bit
deeper in
different smells and different cognitive
issues because
not all smells are smelly for the same
cognitive reasons and for that
also we have to do a little recap of
stuff that we talked about in a previous
video
and stuff that i talked about earlier in
the book is
what exactly happens in your brain what
happens in your brain if you process
like anything
specifically if you process code you
might remember from the previous video
that there are actually
three different types of memory systems
involved firstly if code comes into your
brain like through your eyes and your
senses
code firstly comes into the short term
memory so you read a bit of code and
first it's only
remembered in the short-term memory then
thinking about code processing the code
actually happens in the working memory
that's the the box in the middle and
the lower end so you have working memory
where the code is being processed
while you are thinking about code your
long-term memory
also sends information to your working
memory
so you're not of course reading ac
program like you've never seen
any c or any program before your
long-term memory says hey
here's the semantics of an if statement
and this is what curly brackets mean and
this is what the meaning of that
variable name is so your long-term
memory
is sort of shooting off information to
your working memory like
hey here's some relevant things that you
might also want to consider while
thinking about code this is more or less
what happens in your brain
and we will dive now into what code
smells
sort of mess up in the arrows that are
there
in your brain when you're looking at
code
if we have a smell like a long parameter
list
we have a method that rather than taking
in two or three parameters takes in
12 parameters or something so here's an
example
maybe you have seen some something like
this before this is like a
constructor type of function that takes
in lots of data and then
puts all the arguments on uh on the
object so you see that this list of
parameters is very very long so if you
want to properly
call this method you look at the
definition like
okay what goes in oh country state
city place date average max min
pollutant okay this all goes in so if
you want to call this method
you look at the definition and then you
go to the location of your code where
you want to actually
create an instance of this class you
have to remember
excuse me you have to remember
everything that was there and of course
in some situations ides can help you a
bit there
by also looking at the code and giving
you a list of what is there
but not always and not always enough
so a long parameter list creates an
issue in your short short-term memory
it isn't necessarily that this code is
hard to process
it isn't necessarily that your long-term
memory doesn't know what's going on
it's not it's not hard to understand
right it's not hard to remember what's
going on
the thing that is hard is remembering
everything
and i'm sure you've been in this
situation where you've looked at a
certain
api definition or a definition of a
function
you're like okay so looking at the api
reference okay let's go
so what is there okay this is this in
this order
and then you hop over to your actual
code where you're going to do the api
call and like okay
oh i forgot what was it again you have
to go back to
the definition definition in the code
you have to go go back to
your api rather than oh yeah this was
the order and that sometimes goes like
one or two or three times
which is just like time and energy
wasted
so that is very much a short-term memory
issue
that's why you don't want to create
calls you don't want to create
functions with very long parameter lists
because then you're putting
the burden of remembering everything and
remembering everything in the right
order
on the color of the method so long
parameter list is troublesome because it
overloads the short term memory people
we've talked about this in a previous
video as well
people can only remember between like
five and nine
things at the same time so if your
parameter list
is longer than let's say seven
like in the middle of between uh five
and nine more or less seven is what
people can remember so if you put
more in a parameter list people will not
be able to remember everything in one go
causing this back and forth behavior
looking up the definition
before they can continue with calling
the
function code clones or code duplication
we talked about that right where you
have code
across a code base that that's kind of
similar where you have
a method and somewhere else you have a
slightly different method like here's an
example
i have a a function called foo but i
also have a function called
goo that is slightly different
this is a very very different
cognitive issue so what happens here
is your brain wants to save energy
your brain you might be aware of this
your brain is a big big source of
or drain actually of energy so what your
brain
always wants to do is pattern match it
doesn't want to read all the tiny
details it doesn't want to
spell out in goo all the letters and all
the symbols
it wants to quickly recognize something
you might remember in a previous video
where we had
you remember sentences so this sentence
in a real language that i made up is
very very very hard to remember
but a sentence in a more normal
language it's not really a language but
at least the letters are familiar
what happens here is your brain now
starts to try to create words so if you
look at it maybe in this final word
maybe you just see
bar and not g bar because bar is a word
your brain is now really trying to make
sense of this
because it's one it wants to create
patterns
and if you present something to your
brain that's very very familiar
like actual sentences then rather than
reading c-a-t-l-o-v
yes your brain's just like cat glass
cake
so they're sort of like corner cutting
here
and that corner cutting that is what
makes
code clones so dangerous because we know
you saw this also in the visualization
of the memory system
that your long-term memory supports your
short-term memory
your short-term memory remembers
something and then your long-term memory
is hey
here's some related info this is what
you might be looking at
and that process here where your
long-term memory is
trying to be helpful actually works
against you
if you have code duplication because
what happens if you've seen
many foods in your lifetime very often
you've seen this function
foo that returns j plus plus
your brain sees a goo and it thinks oh i
know this guy
this is a foo and it's gonna return j
plus plus
it doesn't want to read all the details
it wants to make assumptions because
assumptions from long-term memory are
very quick
and efficient very much more efficient
than spelling out all the individual
letters
so the code smell of code duplication
misactivates so to say a very very
different part of your brain
because it's your long-term memory that
gives you information
that isn't helpful it's sort of like
negative help
because if you would read this in detail
if you would really
read letter by letter you would not
assume these two
snippets are the same but you don't want
to read code
letter by letter because in most other
situations
that isn't necessary and that's even
like contra
productive so that is the issue here
where your brain tries to chunk tries to
divide information up in
easy digestible pieces but in its effort
of trying to be helpful
it's actually if it's too helpful and
then it goes wrong
so you see that once you understand a
little bit about these cognitive systems
in your brain
you can look at code smells through a
different lens
and these were just a few examples but
in the book we go into way more detail
about different types of code smells and
how they relate
to underlying cognitive processes
so there's one thing i want to talk
about more
and that's the reason why a different
reason
why all smells are bad so as i said
every code smell has its own issues
all code smells create some sort of
cognitive issue whether in the
short-term memory or in the long-term
memory
or in the working memory but then
there's this additional reason
that all code smells are bad for
cognition
that again has to do with this three
different types of cognitive loads
that i want to zoom in a little bit more
before we end the video
so again consider these three different
types of cognitive load you have
intrinsic load that's just
how difficult the problem is you have
extraneous load that's
extra load added by the phrasing of the
problem so that's the type of load that
code smells might increase
unnecessarily and then you have this
third type of load
germain load that's the load that's
needed to store
something in your long-term memory and
apart from code duplication where your
long-term memory isn't so helpful
in general having a good long-term
memory for
for your code base actually is very
helpful because if you're searching for
information then you don't want to
go through the entire code base finding
something it's really nice if you have a
good long-term memory
for your specific code base so you can
quickly find
information you can quickly gain a
mental model of the code
so as i already said this middle part
is that the the part that code smells
might increase
that might make extra effort because
it's
a different phrasing a different form of
saying something
it could be the case if your code smell
is so bad
that there's so much extraneous load
that there's no more german load so in
the situation
where there's a bit of intrinsic load
and all the rest of your brain
is filled with oh my god what's going on
here oh oh what this is a
long message chain for example oh this
calls this oh this calls this oh this
calls this
then you're very very engaged in
understanding
the problem and we know from cognitive
science
that if your memory working memory is
working really really hard
then this will hamper your ability to
remember
things later there's this paper by
john sweller who is one of the pioneers
of cognitive load theory
in which he compared two groups of kids
so these are kids
learning math and the two groups were
sort of
solving the same problems so the first
group
was doing sort of algebra equations like
this like a
is 7 minus 4a and the second group
was also doing the same equations but
the second group
got a recipe so they got this nice
little formula sheet saying well if you
have an equation that's of the form
a is b minus c a what you can do is you
can take the
minus c a and you can just hop it over
to the other side of the equal sign
but then a minus turns into a plus and
then this
second group as i said did the exact
same math problems
and in this way sweller wanted to
investigate
what is the role of giving recipes
to kids like do they learn math better
or worse if you give them these recipes
to learn on
and it turned out in this experiment
that the recipe group did
way better than the other group really
like spectacularly better and was
just a little bit better they did all
the algebra problems in like
one-fifth of the time of the other group
so much much more fast
the interesting thing though and this is
how it relates to long-term memory and
code smells again
is that this group also did better on
different problems so it wasn't that
they only
learned to do one trick no they actually
remembered how to
do these things because something like
moving something to the other side of
the equal sign
that's useful in many many different
situations
so this group because their brains
weren't so full because they weren't
very engaged in problem solving just a
little bit
they didn't have that much extraneous
load they just had a little bit
they could remember something so the
hypothesis here that sweller posed
is that if you do something that is not
all too difficult that's sort of
reasonable in complexity
you have a little bit of green a little
bit of germain
load left to actually store strategies
to store
information about the problems
the other group the group that was very
very engaged in problem solving and that
ultimately also got the right answers it
just took them more time
didn't have any green didn't have any
german rooms in their brains left
tying this back to code smells is that
if you are engaging with very very
complicated code
your brain is like the brains of those
kids in the study
where there's a bit of intrinsic load a
bit of yeah a bit of red
and everything else is blue it takes you
much more effort to read to dive into to
understand
code with code smells and my book
actually goes into
into depth also how we exactly measure
cognitive load and
how we know that code with code smells
actually
takes more effort to read they then lots
and lots of
cool experiments where people were like
headbands where you can measure brain
waves while people
read smelly code lots more detail about
that in the book if you're interested to
check that out
so we know scientifically that code
smells
create more cognitive load in the brain
it is very likely that that is the case
that there's
less or in some cases no germane
load left and what happens and i am
i have fallen victim to this many times
where i was reading very complicated
code and i was very much
in the code right i was like oh this
goes there okay this is the name of that
parameter oh this class oh this
api call and i managed to understand
the code in a brief moment of time i was
like okay i get it now
now i can fix this one bug okay now i
can add this one feature okay
i have everything it's right there
and then you step away you you bike home
from the office
like before grovid or you you go for
like a coffee
and then you come back to the code maybe
like the day after or like an hour after
after a meeting
and you're like i don't remember
anything i know i can look at kit hub
and i can see that i am the one that put
in this feature yesterday
i have no recollection of what i did
if you've ever been in such a situation
that was because you had
too little german load left because you
were so engaged with the code
that your storage your long-term memory
was like
i have no clue what just happened that
is
an additional reason apart from the
specific cognitive issues that each code
smell poses
this is an additional issue that holds
for any
complicated code if code takes you so
much effort that
all your brain has to be engaged to
understand the code
it's very likely that you will not have
any
maybe not any memory right that you will
have not enough memory
the day or the week after so that's an
extra reason
why we don't want to write smelly code
not just because it's more error prone
and it's giving more cognitive load but
also it will inhibit
yourself in the future but also new
people
coming into your code base to quickly
gain an
understanding to quickly build up their
long-term memory
relationship with this code because all
of the time they're so engaged
that they're not remembering anything so
that's it
that's everything i wanted to share with
you today if you want to check out
more about me more about the work i do
you can follow me on twitter i'm at
felina on twitter
and you can go to my website as well
which is convenientlyjustmyfirstname.com
felina.com if you like listening to me
you want to listen to me lots more for
free
that is possible because i'm one of the
hosts of the podcast
software engineering radio a weekly show
where
me and a bunch of other hosts interview
top
names from software engineering about
all sorts of stuff
programming languages databases
distributed systems
so if you want to check us out we're on
spotify and itunes for free
and of course if you want to know more
about my book you can go to flyna.com
the book is called the programmer's
brain and it talks about
all sorts of programming related
concepts like
code smells that we talked about today
and
naming and learning new new programming
languages
but all very much from the cognitive
perspective
answering the question like what happens
in your brain
if you read code if you maintain code if
you onboard people
into your code base so that's already
out as a manning early access program so
you can now read the first nine chapters
online and pre-order
the book that's it thank you so much for
watching